hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you oh
[Music]
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing I recently came
across a video a very short video of a
popular atheist who I've refuted in the
past many of you have seen those
refutations Neil deGrasse Tyson
talking about god let's take a look at
that video and come back and comment
do you believe in God creator yeah so
I'm the the more I look at the universe
um just the less convinced I am that
there is something benevolent going on
so if you if if your concept of a
creator
is someone who's all-powerful
and all good and I look at
disasters that afflict Earth and life on
Earth volcanoes hurricanes tornadoes
earthquakes disease
pestilence
um congenital birth defects you look at
this list of ways that life is made
miserable on Earth by natural causes
and I just ask how do you deal with that
so philosophers rose up and said if
there is a God
God is either not all-powerful
or not all good I have no problems if as
we probe the origins of things we bump
up into the bearded man if that shows up
we're good to go okay not a problem
there's just no evidence of it now there
are two things that one can spot really
with this video the first thing I would
say is he makes an argument really
against God and this is a very famous
argument the problem of evil
now I've covered the entire problem of
evil with the Institute the sapiens
Institute and you can put my name in the
sapiens Institute on YouTube and you'll
find an entire video where we speak
about this at length but suffice it for
me to say at this point
when he says that philosophers have
risen up and spoken you know or put the
following proposition forward
uh that if God is all an omnipotent or
powerful and all good then how could
there be evil because it would negate
one of the two attributes and obviously
I'm simplifying here
um that this is kind of an argument in
for him an undercutting argument for
God's existence
now I'll just put two or three things uh
to you maybe just to make you think
about the matter number one how do you
define evil from a scientific
perspective being a naturalist being a
physicalist being and materialist being
an individual who doesn't see anything
above and beyond the physical world
meaning if something is not empirically
verifiable something that you cannot put
under a microscope with some kind of
form matter of substance then it really
doesn't exist as a figment of one's
imagination now I want to know from Neil
deGrasse Tyson this evil that he speaks
of this evil or this these disasters
that he speaks of all these negative
things that he speaks of can you put
this thing under the microscope
can you put Evil under the microscope
when he says that God is how can evil
exist in the world he's he is citing
epicurus a Hellenistic philosopher
um and this is when he says the
philosophers he means this particular
philosopher because this is the person
who brings forward this argument can you
put Evil under the microscope so
therefore does evil exist on your
physicalist materialist
paradigm
this is the first question and if it
doesn't exist of course then what is
this question worth it's worth nothing
at all there's no currency in the
questioning
but let's assume for the sake of
argument that evil does exist and
somehow maybe you can put it under your
microscope okay
why do you assume that theists like
Muslims for example or others or even
Christians to be fair or Jews believe in
a god with only two attributes
omnipotence and goodness
why do you assume that that's what we
believe
we believe in a god with many attributes
and of course one of them is wisdom we
as Muslims believe that Allah is which
means the most wise and what is wisdom
wisdom from the Islamic perspective is
appropriacy the idea of putting
something in its rightful place meaning
as the Quran says something which is
negative or which you don't like could
be good for you as
that you could hate something but it's
good for you
so all these disasters that you've cited
which of course are not limited to for
example the earthquake that we saw
uh in in turkey and of course uh in
Syria which we make for Allah for the
relief of those people how do you know
that it's not either a test or an
elevation of those individuals who have
been murdered or or who have sort of
been killed in the earthquake
or we believe as Muslims they've been
martyred sahib as one of the things in
the Hadith has mentioned the person
who's been of a collapse building on
them is one of the martyrs is actually
Hadith in in our tradition so it could
be that there is a wisdom behind some of
the things which we as individuals find
negative and of course if we assume a
god with only two attributes we are
eliminating this possibility so I think
we're done here with epicuruses
uh you know conundrum or dilemma which
quite frankly even atheist philosophers
of course you're not one of them because
you're an astrophysicist who's delving
into things or fields which are not his
own have even admitted like William Rowe
that this is an intellectually bankrupt
case anyway that this problem of evil
objection or interrogation to the theist
is something which is not really
effectual is intellectually bankrupt but
that's something else then he a
nonchalantly or I could say audaciously
mentions at the end of his video that if
you have evidence then bring it forward
but if you've got some good evidence
bring it bring bring it bring it it's as
if he doesn't know that there have been
evidences put forward by
the likes of even Aristotle all the way
up to present-day enlightened figures
and Beyond from all traditions for the
for the existence of God ontological
arguments teleological arguments
fine-tuning arguments cosmological
arguments you have not engaged with
those arguments
anybody even an re student in GCSE level
knows Aquinas is five ways Thomas
Aquinas has five ways to prove in God's
existence
everybody most people Now understand
what a fine-tuning argument is and what
kind of permutations is taken whether
William paley's fine-tuning argument of
the watchmakers argument you've got to
watch on the uh you know and what is it
there's the contrivance he calls it is
there some creation or is there none
or the argument that uh you know you've
got all these elect you've got these
constants you've got the electromagnetic
constant something more in your
wavelength and you've got the
gravitational constant and that they are
in a life permitting range and had that
these uh constants not been a you know a
particular way in the in Richard Dawkins
own words the Goldilocks zone then there
would not be any life at all
it's as if you don't know these
arguments
so don't say present the evidence
because of course what do you mean by
evidence
and this is the thing you have the
audacity to reject types of evidence we
present a cosmological type of argument
then maybe it's not satisfactory if you
present an ontological type of argument
so what kind of evidence will you be
willing to accept
and let me just end this conversation
really because it's as if I need to
explain this to you in other places in
debates in other presentations I've
outlined the contingency argument for
God's existence the cosmological
argument fine-tuning arguments I'm not
going to do that now
because that will take too much of my
space and time but suffice it for me to
say one thing in terms of this whole
question of evidence one thing only that
the universe is a certain way it has
certain physical properties that we can
all agree on right okay if the universe
has a certain way and has certain
physical properties
the physical properties of the universe
okay allow life to exist we all agree no
problem now tell me what is a better
explanation that you have an
intelligence or knowledge that has
brought forth this reality or that you
have no knowledge that there is no there
is no mover there is no Intelligence on
mind for you which is it if you say the
latter than that it itself requires an
explanation which of course the atheist
is
deplete of any kind of explanation
atheism itself has no it doesn't have
any explanatory scope or power
so with that I'll let you think
from whence did the uniformity the
regularity and the stability of the
universe that is allowing human beings
or any other life form to exist come
from did it come from a life permitting
force or an intelligence or some
knowledge or did it come from no such
thing
be honest with yourself and answer this
question
and I believe if you're being honest
with yourself
you will look at yourself in the mirror
and realize
that it is the former rather than the
latter if you don't want to live with
that realization then no that you are
lying to yourself deluding yourself The
Atheist delusion it will be for you
the prophet Muhammad
sallam told us whoever builds a mosque
for Allah Allah will build for him a
similar house in Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays that whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale